what what percent of guys do you think
are over six foot
one percent
lucky guess 56 56 I'm gonna say 35 35 42
42. huh
um Harmony
I'm not drunk guys
um I would say 30 30 so it's only 15 of
guys wow and now think about it think
about it if uh how many people said they
have an X over six foot you did you did
you did all sleeping with the same guys
are sleeping with the same guys because
80 of women want 20 of men
no that is Matt so so the reason like
women think men are trash and they think
they're sleeping around all the time is
because we go for such a small
percentage of of men and they are
sleeping around all the time the
majority of men if you go to Tesco you
think they're getting any play
okay so you will say and you're saying
it comes to our choice in men right that
makes us think the rest of the same I
think that's the first statement
actually yeah I agree with that
yes that's a very interesting thing
because I feel like a lot of the time
like women when they're younger yeah
they go for like the bad boy or like
something as you get older you kind of
realize that like certain traits that
you would like find attractive like
someone who's emotionally unavailable
they become unattractive as you get
older you're only 22 right I know what
have you been in a relationship but you
know I've seen so many like people get
into relationships and it's just and it
all flops something and it's like yeah
I'm scared
I'm actually terrified so um have you
guys had a toxic ax yep yes
um it wasn't an X but I guess yeah sort
of toxic yeah okay
um nope I've had people who felt like
they're obliged
by having a say in my life because they
like me
that's not yes or no I need a yes or no
no no no no
me I would say yeah yeah okay um how
long were you involved with your toxic
ex a year and a half yeah did you love
him yes yes five years five years oh my
oh my goodness that is mad five years
yeah that is crazy did you love him
that's how you know it's toxic five
years you didn't love him I don't know
it was I wasn't like in a relationship
with him but it was just a very toxic
situation so
okay so you know you didn't love him yes
or no
um I don't know maybe it was love to me
at the time at the time I don't think
it's love like now when I look back on
it okay wow five years okay so I
actually never been in a relationship
like properly where I can say oh you
know with boyfriend and girlfriend yeah
but I've been in a lot of situations
where I'm taking a guy and I would say
yeah I miss going it's been quite toxic
so yeah you would yes yes and how long
were you with him oh
I was with him for about
must be not five months not long five
months yeah I'm a busy woman I haven't
really got time did you did you love him
no no
okay so question question based on this
panel two out of four of you said you
loved your toxic acts and you were with
him for over a year would you say by
that statement young women love toxic
men
yes yes do you know what it is I think
when you're young you don't really know
your boundaries properly yet and a lot
of people put up with stuff that they
wouldn't usually put up with like I
always say now like men only treat you
bad if you let them if you let them yeah
if you let them treat you man and you
don't if you don't respect your
boundaries then they're gonna walk all
over you and I think that's just bad
guys though I think that's just bad guys
like I think there's something about
young women like picking the Bad Boys
[Music]
they're gonna walk all over you if you
treat them well that's just yeah no 100
I'm the youngest in here and I will tell
you it's because it's exciting it's like
almost like an adrenaline
bounce off each other I knew it when she
was talking about the following I was
like she likes to draw
yeah itchy but I also feel like yeah
it's not sorry I also feel like it
depends on your circumstances as the
young girl because I with me I depended
on my ex for living for food for
everything so I felt like I was chained
to him like I was his had no one else
you know so it was like circumstances
made me in be in that situation so what
about that situation was toxic uh oh
well he was basically like cheating
around flirting with other girls at work
um I didn't know obviously because I was
just like at home I didn't have a job I
was just like living off him you know
but I feel like he he
um had that power over me because I
allowed him to obviously so yeah so she
was it more than cheating or was he a
good boyfriend outside it was more than
cheating I was involved in certain
things as well so I felt like if he did
if if he could do I could do it to you
okay so you were cheating you were both
cheating on each other and couldn't you
just on a standstill and then got along
um no because I mean
we did have conversations about it we we
were very open with each other but then
obviously the cheating was lies he
because he kept it from me so did you
keep your cheating from him no I told
him I told him you don't know you don't
want to know who I cheated on him with
but um
is he famous no he's not no no no okay
no no you don't know
okay I cheated on him with his sister
listen if you break me I will break you
back
[Laughter]
in your right mind I'm a changed person
I am a changed person I'm a change
person okay so what
why why is sister I'm just gonna sit my
dream me and his sister were really good
friends I mean clearly
no no
[Laughter]
friends and obviously one day she said
she wanted to come over and I said cool
he was at work we got drunk and she
started like pouncing on me okay I'm not
even trying to like I'm so serious like
she and I was like no like this isn't
right and she's like no and then Boop it
happened and I was like [__] and then
you told him yeah I told him how did he
react he almost killed me was she
younger how old was she she was younger
yeah but we had a conversation about it
and
I can't pay out his ethnicity anyway
um it's it's almost like common from
where he's from
we're gonna
okay so South Africa and stuff wow
no but um it's not common but it was
like a thing within his
[Laughter]
but because I'm regardless of whether I
did something wrong or not regardless of
whether I hurt someone's feeling or not
I am an honest person and I feel like
that's very very important if you're if
you're talking to someone if you're in a
relationships with someone if you're
just with people anyway you know so I I
just I clarified that with him he got
upset he came back and he was like thank
you for being honest with me you know so
it was like yeah but he was toxic for
cheating on you and not telling you yes
I had to find out would you would you
rather have him told you yes do you
think men lie to women they care about
or that they or they tell the truth to
women they lie to women they care about
and they feel like maybe like certain
characteristics that they have for
example
um some because some women are really
Stern like if you cheat on me that's it
and because they care so much they don't
want to lose you so that thought of
having to lose you would now be in be in
their head obviously and yeah they
wouldn't they wouldn't tell you so
outside of the cheating anything else
toxic or just that
um
yeah we smoked a lot of stuff
okay so I guess that's drugs
I guess that was toxic okay
um all right what about you
um
what was the question
um what was toxic about you said you had
a toxic situationship yeah what was
toxic about it um it was very
emotionally abusive so like even though
I see myself as a strong person but
there's only so many times you can like
get knocked down and I dealt with it and
I feel like I didn't respect my own
boundaries which led to me being in that
situation
um yeah it was just very unhealthy what
is emotional abuse
um I think to constantly knock someone's
confidence down make them feel bad about
themselves
like what specifically
um
I don't know like it could really be
anything like you know just I'm asking
like to you like what did he say like
what how was he emotionally abusive oh
he just like just used to knock me down
like I used to be a bit slow because I
had a history of like doing like party
drugs okay I feel like it actually
affected my like mental development a
bit like I had a stutter for a long time
like I was a bit slow and it was one of
my biggest insecurities and I used to
get digged out a lot for that like oh
you're so slow you're stupid you're this
and that's what he would say to you yeah
and also
um I lost a lot of weight because of
stress and I was very insecure in my
skin like you're so skinny like lost so
much weight and I just want you to feel
like a bit rubbish about myself
um and what did what did you say to him
back like did you push back or what yeah
I would push back I would tell him like
don't talk to me like that or I don't
like that I'm running because he did
used to like threaten me and stuff but
he used to threaten you yeah he was he
wasn't like threatened threatened to do
like what kill you or no like just to
like you know bring his fists up to me
and stuff I knew he would never do
anything but like yeah it was just not a
nice situation I would always Stand My
Ground about that but I would continue
to put up with it for so long so that's
why
like I was disrespected for so long but
yeah literally after I got out of it I
put on weight like I was I got a glow
like life was good oh we love our happy
ending yeah
um what about no you you said yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
I relate to her as well because you know
what it is now I'm hearing both stories
maybe I haven't actually been in a toxic
um relationship you say or toxic X but
everyone has their own meaning of toxic
at the end of the day obviously I'm sure
there is like a meaning by book but
everyone has their like
yeah yeah one meaning yeah yeah you know
what I'm trying to say but yeah
basically I think with me obviously
um it wasn't for that long I think I
think was toxicity is like he was saying
he wanted to see me but didn't see me
and this was like that for about eight
months so he was saying he'd want to see
you and then he wouldn't see you
next plans of you and lets you down
with me you cannot take a bite with me
I'll be like leave then stop leading me
honestly I'm not leaving you off have
you ever um promised to go on a date and
not go went not went have you ever worn
off a guy yeah are you guys all toxic
yeah
yeah but women aren't demonized for it
men are we call it entertainment
[Laughter]
you can say like a rotation
entertainment hahaha but when a guy says
that he's toxic yeah that's absolutely
because he says the exact same thing
women can be just as bad as men though
some women are actually demons like yeah
evil pure evil yeah tell me who are you
thinking of what story
no I've just like seen how like some
women treat men and like you know
um some women can be very narcissistic I
think
social media especially has like become
a breeding ground for narcissism and a
lot of people but I do also think the
times thrown around very Loosely and a
lot of people are accused of being a
narcissist when they're actually not
never what girl you said you could think
of a narcissistic girls or a story yeah
[Music]
um I mean I could use like my I don't
know I don't know any narcissistic women
stories oh you've heard stories I've
Heard lots of stories and it's it's
actually like heartbreaking because a
lot of the time these men really care
for these women unless they're trapped
in this abusive you know what a lot of
girls trap guys by getting pregnant
a lot and then they have all this baby
it's like it's mad no but you know what
it is yeah when it comes to like
trapping a man with a baby you need to
be careful who you sleep with if you're
sleeping with people Loosely and you you
run the risk of getting that person
pregnant so you have to you have to sit
like that remember we said earlier about
if you you only go into a place to date
that person you don't that person you
want to be with them and you're getting
very short because of trust and then
you'd only sleep with that person if
you're like don't mean that yeah at the
same time at the same time
you need to wrap up because yeah yeah as
much as it takes two to tango you need
to protect yourself for your own good
like yeah yeah the woman can say she's
on the pill she's on this she's on that
but like but still at the same time
protect yourself you said you've you've
heard of a girl trapping a guy tell me
about that oh
obviously
[Music]
um yeah he was obviously dating I think
this like girl only fans go and
um yeah and then obviously his energy
kind of Switched right and she was quite
um
toxic I know she talks because she used
to I have some other girls she's a block
she used to go on his phone and block
certain goals oh wow and um he used to
go and she'd go through people's like
insta stories
who he follows that makes sense yeah
that makes sense yeah and then
afterwards um
obviously who knows how she got pregnant
oh wow yeah and then um but obviously
again it was it was it wasn't serious he
was doing it mainly for pleasure because
of her body right she's got a nice body
okay cool what else can you bring to the
table you know we've got beautiful lady
panelists tonight we've all got body
body yeah but we you know what I mean
but we've got more than that hence why
we're here today that's right that's
what I'm trying to say but obviously in
the in that case I'm obviously trapping
him but it's crazy because now it's
messed up his career a little bit he
obviously didn't want it he did not
really taking responsibility and he's
kind of like hiding away from everyone
almost and obviously that can impact the
man mentally as well I think a lot of
people don't focus on a man's mental
health as well and I think females are
all we're all like are we emotional
we've got feelings but obviously men are
taught to obviously keep that away but
but also what I would say is like once a
woman like when a woman actually falls
pregnant it's a very very very difficult
decision to make whether to keep it or
to get rid of it
how do you fall pregnant
yeah it's a it's an actual baby so I
mean you might tell yourself oh I don't
want a baby and then you fall pregnant
and you're like oh [__] like what have I
done yeah what have I done like I
actually want to keep this baby now or
I'm gonna that's what I feel like a lot
of people do you guys don't think about
the consequences of your actions you're
always relying I feel like this
generation is so much awareness yeah are
you present are you aware of like what
you're doing and the concept Our
Generation yeah mostly women yeah
women I would say women use it as a
former I would say we use it as a form
of birth control which is not good which
is not good by the way I mean I know
people might have different
um views but I say that's not good yeah
I think if you don't want to get
pregnant then you need to like take the
precautions to not get pregnant
obviously if you need to have an
abortion and then like you get it
I like because there's women out there
that can't have children and then if you
get a lot of abortions that can actually
stop you from having kids in the future
that is very true that is very true
because I took the pill so many times I
now suffer from polycystic ovarian
syndrome so it's hard for me to actually
get pregnant
unfortunately I haven't seen my period
for four years but recently I got my
period through some profit that prayed
for me and yeah I'm delivered guys
miracle from like from what did you get
it from the pill like so like do you
mean the morning after pill or the the
morning after pill yeah I took that too
many times and I also went on the pill
how many times did you take it I think
like six seven times six seven times
within the span of how long
um with an oh maybe like a month six
seven in a month wow yeah and did you
know that was a possible side effect no
I didn't and how did you find out that
you had that this was actually well what
the policy government when I was in a
relationship with my toxic ex because I
noticed that he would obviously inside
of you and then I would notice that I
wasn't like getting pregnant and I was
gaining so much weight really quickly
and
um I started growing excess excess hair
in certain places so those are all the
side effects of getting um polycystic
ovarian syndromes and then I went to the
doctors found out I had it and yeah
what was that like for you it was scary
because I love kids I'm I am a child
myself you know like I love laughs I
love playing I love to just be me
everywhere so kids was a big factor for
me but I knew that in due time things
will work out in my favor and I will get
the kids that I want it's not impossible
not to have kids but it's harder 10
times harder do you wish they told you
about that um before you before I took
yes a thousand percent yeah it's um a
thousand percent because I feel like a
lot of girls really don't know about the
side effects and they don't discuss them
the doctors don't tell you I've never
really been on it because when I heard
about birth control I was like you're
gonna stop me from getting pregnant yeah
education in that aspect when it comes
to contraception methods it's not that
good the teacher a little bit at school
but not completely like real deal but
even when you go and like get it
prescribed the doctor don't really tell
you nothing and you know what there's so
many women that go on contraception and
then they can't they struggle to get
pregnant afterwards
utility goes back to normal straight
away and it doesn't and some people are
trying for a baby and three years down
the line they still can't have a child
because everyone's body is different as
well everyone's Body Works differently
yeah yeah it's hard
do you guys believe that the label toxic
is overused in relationships today yes
I mean look at me like what time
you've been liking about that common now
like really I don't know hearing them
stories that you know there's different
like I said there's different um Heights
of toxic levels of toxicness and again
it's what you perceive the word toxic to
mean so but I do think that toxic
relationships and like just with anyone
like friends yeah partners and stuff
it's like really like promoted on social
media it is it's like the toxic
relationship Lifestyles like toxic love
like everyone yeah and what's his name
blue face
so much I don't get so much attention
for that and it's like so unhealthy
they're probably both so depressed and
unhappy I feel like trying to be toxic
you have to have a very strong head yeah
like you don't have to be toxic they
know what they're doing it's like they
don't it's not like they don't know what
they're doing it's like it's like it's
calculated yeah they're doing it on
purpose but what I've seen that's what
it looks like yeah I mean to be honest I
feel like with toxic relationships you
get that Adrenaline Rush from like when
things are good and then when it goes
like really bad you just think about the
good times which is why are you stay
with that person you feel like you're
making excuses for yourself to stay yeah
and obviously it's so up and down like
once it goes down you're like oh my God
I can't wait for it to like go back up
again like and everything to be good
because you guys go through like really
good faces a little bit of Hope almost
yeah good part or sometimes you're just
used to this is your comfort zone now
yeah
the cons will eventually outweigh the
pose I mean that's when you know how do
you get used to it
no but some people have grown up in even
like a toxic household like with toxic
families like also like how someone's
been raised has a big impact on like the
type of men they go for women also like
drama
[Music]
why don't women watch sports that's
camaraderie we like the Kardashians oh
my God I love the Kardashians
[Laughter]
watch me in a year's time I'm gonna be
sitting with Kim Kardashian she's gonna
be me and her gonna be pretending that
manifestation obviously each other
working on you know skins X I've got a
cover line jumping suit as well dreaming
my music so mad Madness told you as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible